there's no shortage of theories and
questions concerning the incredibly
popular predator films from the aliens
true nature to the future of the
franchise here are facts about the
predator series that aren't really facts
at all
to begin with one thing to know about
predators is that they're not really
predators it sounds confusing but it's
true it's even pointed out directly by
the biologist casey brackett played by
olivia munn in the predator it hunts
people for sport technically that's not
a it's not a predator it's like kind of
thank you after all while predator is a
great name for a movie about an alien
who comes to earth just to kill people
that doesn't mean it's technically
accurate as a label for the creature in
the natural world a predator is a
creature that kills another organism for
food that last bit is important
predators as in actual earth animals in
nature kill because they need to eat in
contrast to predators who appear in the
sci-fi franchise of the same name kill
for sport or to prove their own prowess
as hunters something that appears to be
highly valued in their culture their
predators don't eat their kills they
just skin them hang them upside down and
sometimes remove their skulls and spines
to wave around triumphantly they don't
want meat they want trophies by
definition they're not predators that
said for the sake of clarity we're still
going to call them predators
if you haven't seen the predator movies
or if you just haven't paid that much
attention it makes sense to believe that
there's one primary predator throughout
the franchise after all the titles for
every film except one 2010's predators
are singular there's a predator and in
2018 he was the predator of course none
of that is true the main predator when
there is one dies in literally every
movie the title creature of 1987's
predator blows himself up with a
self-destruct device after being
grievously wounded by dutch schaefer
played by arnold schwarzenegger the
urban hunter of predator 2 is killed in
battle with mike harrigan played by
danny glover all of the predators and
predators are taken down by their
intended prey and the oversized
genetically hybridized creature at the
center of the predator is taken down by
that movie's central characters as well
the thing about predators of course is
that there are always more of them
furthermore it's pretty clear at this
point that's hunting humans presumably
alongside other sentient creatures from
around the galaxy is a cherished
tradition on their planet so they're
just going to keep doing it no matter
how many die trying
particularly with the first and most
beloved film in the series some of the
franchise's most iconic imagery comes
from the predator's point of view
showing schwarzenegger and other cast
members in bright colours that represent
the intensity of their body heat as the
creature hunts them through the dense
jungle this has led some viewers to
mistakenly think that the predator
species has actually evolved to see with
thermal imaging if you pay attention
however it becomes pretty clear that
this infrared imaging is technological
and contained in the lenses of the
predator's masks in predator 2 the
extraterrestrial hunter has multiple
vision modes he can switch between and
while we never see that happen in the
original film it's hard to deny that the
other worldly villain here must have
other forms of vision as well for
example how could he so easily avoid all
the traps set for him by the commandos
if all he can see is he's plus in the
fantastic scene where he first takes his
mask off we watch as his vision
completely changes with the infrared
disappearing from sight
it's not just the predators who die and
are replaced for every movie of the six
predator movies released to date the two
avp movies not a single installment
features a returning human character
from a previous movie after more than
three decades of that same formula it
starts to look like none of the movies
are really connected at all the two most
recent installments in particular seem
to bear the hallmarks of franchise
reboots predators spoiler alert moves
the action from earth to an alien planet
while the predator has a new military
base story and a title distinguished
from the first movie only by the article
the
of course this isn't the case for either
sci-fi flick aside from the more
complicated avp installments each
predator movie establishes that the
previous films did indeed happen even if
the events have been classified so that
most people don't know about them in
predator 2 government agent peter keys
played by gary busey discusses the
events of the first movie in predators
the characters of isabel played by alice
braga recognizes the predators from a
description of the events of the
original predator in the predator the
events of the first two movies are
discussed and further confirmed as real
by the presence of sean keys the son of
peter keys from predator 2 who's played
by gary busey's actual son jake
whatever character he's playing arnold
schwarzenegger tends to be regarded as
the ultimate badass and not without
reason his godlike physique and apparent
strength have placed him on a level
above other action heroes especially in
the 1980s it was a time when superhero
physiques weren't as widespread in
movies as they've become in the era of
cinema today so it makes perfect sense
when schwarzenegger's dutch survives the
deaths of his teammates in predator and
has a final showdown with the alien
creature all on his own he's basically
earth's champion in that moment and he's
fighting for us all but contrary to what
you might think he's not the only human
to defeat a predator in single combat in
predator 2 dany glovers mike harrigan
single-handedly takes down a predator of
his own and his win might have been even
more impressive the other predators
certainly seem to think so you don't
know what you're dealing with
after the death of peter keys who
thought he had the predator's number and
was quickly proven wrong harrigan and
the titular alien are left on their own
however harrigan manages to sever one of
the creature's arms robbing it of its
self-destruct mechanism he then follows
the predator into an underground
spaceship and defeats it with its own
blade other predators appear and carry
off the dead body and the leader then
honors harrigan's prowess by giving him
an anti-gun that it had apparently taken
on a previous hunt
few sequels are as commonly maligned as
predator 2. it came in fourth at the box
office on its opening weekend was
critically panned and later instalments
in the franchise were celebrated for
ignoring it it's not a classic like its
predecessor and there's a good chance
you haven't even seen it if that's the
case go watch predator 2 and decide for
yourself because it actually has a lot
going for it it's a clear and deliberate
departure from the first movie but
that's a better choice in trying to
duplicate the original predator had
jungle action pretty well covered so
predator 2 brought its titular alien
hunter to the streets of downtown los
angeles what's more it's the near future
los angeles in which gangs rule the city
cops barely stand a chance and
everybody's guns still shoot bullets but
they're weirdly big and chunky looking
the aforementioned dany glover is the
hero as different from arnold
schwarzenegger as an action star could
be in fact it's ultimately glover's
performance as a detective who simply
won't quit no matter what he's up
against that makes predator 2 something
of an underrated gem
in predator the captured rebel anna
played by el padilla carrillo is the
only survivor besides schwarzenegger's
dutch in predator 2 the hunter corners
detective leona cantrell and then
decides not to kill her it also spares
an unnamed woman at the site of a
massacre in a drug lord's penthouse in
alien vs predator the central predator
actually befriends lex woods played by
sinar lathan and works with her to
defeat the aliens isabel survives
predators and casey brackett survives
the predator so what's the deal do
predators not kill women the truth is
that in theory they might but these
movies don't really have enough women
for them to kill predators don't
necessarily care about gender they just
don't kill unarmed people it also seems
that they don't kill pregnant people
which is why detective cantrell is
spared the drug lord's girlfriend also
falls under the unarmed rule there's
also very few female action heroes in
these movies so it would have been a
bummer for audiences to see them
slaughtered anna and isabelle are
literally the only female characters in
their respective films and cantrell is
just about the only woman in predator 2
who's not a drug lord's unclothed
girlfriend so killing them would have
just seemed really dark at the end of
the day what also keeps the predators
from killing women is the narrative
choices of these movies
as part of the gadget-filled techno
armor they prefer to wear when hunting
humans each predator has a metal face
mask that they generally don't lose
until the final showdown when it's time
to give the heroes and the audience a
good look at that creepy man-dibbled
face because predators show up to earth
wearing this mask and don't usually take
it off until shortly before they die a
lot of people assume that the mask is
what enables them to breathe in earth's
atmosphere if you pay attention however
that's clearly not the case the first
predator does without a mask for a long
time while fighting dutch in the jungle
and he seems to breathe just fine in
predator 2 the creature is seen
breathing through another device after
losing his mask but we don't know
exactly why maybe los angeles famous
smog is too much for him this same movie
establishes that predators breathe the
same air as humans however because
harrigan can breathe inside their
spaceship even when interacting with an
unmasked extraterrestrial the same thing
is true of the alien planet in predators
the humans can breathe there just fine
and so can the unmasked hunters there's
no doubt the mask provides copious tools
to aid a predator's survival starting
with that famous thermal vision but a
breathing apparatus is not one of them
released in 2018 the predator was only a
midling's success at the box office and
it was widely panned by critics these
days however it takes a lot more than a
bad installment or two to kill a sci-fi
action franchise like the predators
themselves the franchise just keeps
getting up and coming for its prey in
this case moviegoers in fact the next
movie is already in production it's
currently being called skulls but it's
likely to be re-titled something with
the word predator in it before release
the upcoming installment will star amber
mid thunder of legion as a comanche
woman who wants to be a warrior and
eventually encounters a predator in the
19th century 10 cloverfield lane
director dan trachtenberg is helming the
movie so it should at least be
interesting and if it doesn't work that
will be disappointing but it wouldn't
likely be the end surely the predators
will keep returning to their favorites
hunting ground earth's movie screens
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]